so there I was surrounded by my friends
and already for my happy ever after at
least that's how I pictured it the
reality was much more single
screw off still not to dwell on the
negatives many positives to note I'm
absolutely loving my new light have top
job as a producer of news program I'm
looking for someone dynamic to lead any
volunteers do you need the bathroom
budget and maintaining good relationship
with X oh yeah very well thanks how are
you I'm fine
pacified level whiskey please big laugh
double and my love life is showing signs
of improvement
maiya
it's Fitz aside from one tiny
development I'm pregnant
everything is completely under control
sort of
it's Evan look at you oh no Bridget
who's the fart of that this is Marx
there's at least a 50% chance did you
have a three-way so this is dad I
presume so glad you could be here this
is a unique and wonderful moment if you
could maybe give me a safer sir this is
dad I presume I'm so glad you could be
here this is unique and marvelous moment
I saved this company by cutting out of
babies handed to package deliveries
Monday it'll all be yours falling any
monument they screw up julep well what
is that